grosse pression ce soir au sein de
l'association d'insertion envie à
trappes c'est en présence d'un ministre
est sous les feux des projecteurs que
ces deux jeunes filles signent leurs
emplois d'avenir les premiers du
département avant les 1600 à venir pour
cette année avec men et c'était très
content parce que j'ai jamais ainsi être
assuré le ministre cadets télé c'était
souvent tous ces beaux chiens ce contrat
d'avenir que j'ai signé aujourd'hui
c'est un poste de secrétaire comptable
donc en cdi voilà donc après j'aurai
droit à une formation
grâce à ce contrat la formation de pays
de comptabilité ces emplois d'avenir
sont l'une des réponses du gouvernement
pour réduire le chômage des jeunes ce
sont des cdi ou des cdd de trois ans il
s'adresse aux 16 25 ans peu ou pas
qualifiés et les formations peuvent
aller jusqu'à bac +3 en échange de cette
embauche les entreprises sont exonérées
en partie de charges sociales sur les
contrats de travail qui permet déjà de
se projeter dans l'avenir c'est du temps
plein c'est minimum au smic ne connais
pas sur contrat
au rabais au passage benoît hamon
inaugure la première antenne pour
l'ile-de-france du réseau envie
entreprise de réinsertion positionner
sur le recyclage d'appareils
électroménagers le ministre souhaite
booster l'économie sociale et solidaire
notamment dans les yvelines et rappelle
que les entreprises de le ss ont été
plus robuste dans la crise que les
entreprises du capital et ont
généralement une durée de vie plus
longue le réseau envie existe depuis
plus de 20 ans l'antenne de trappes
emploie aujourd'hui 17 salariés dont
onze personnes en réinsertion